schafft es diese frage ins kino warst du
warst ja warum nicht
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum mit abstand
besten kino das ist jemals bei schlau
gegeben hat aber das ist dieses juni ist
für alle die sich fragen wer ist
eigentlich dieser meitingen geben und
wie spricht man ihren nachnamen aus wie
mein nachname ausspricht habt ihr jetzt
zwar nicht gefragt aber es ist mit
abstand die häufigste frage die ich in
mir live gestellt bekomme und kein name
name
schätzungsweise 40 prozent aller
vietnamesen tragen diesen namen und da
sehr viele asiaten hier in deutschland
auch wir in der lesen sind
jedes höchste zeit dass man mal
reinhören ausspricht hören wir zu
ähnlich ausgesprochen wie das nun von
nürnberg statt einmal gegen nürnberg
sagt man einfach martin mühe gibt nicht
so schwer oder die ein bisschen
sprachlich begabt darin können das ng
versuchen auszusprechen
eigentlich ist das genauso wie das
entgegen deutsch nur hier haben wir es
immer als endungen endungen nur wenn ihr
das so aussprechen könnte ist es schon
ziemlich gut in wirklichkeit ist
vietnamesisch eine tonale sprache würden
es gibt jeden nordvietnamesische
aussprache und es gibt die südsee der
mäßige aussprache hohen verlusten sowie
dazu das wollte ich nur mal kurz los
werden die häufigste frage die ich
gestellt bekomme im leben jetzt kommen
wir zu euren fragen roboter alter freund
dieser sendung wärst du lieber ein
depressives einhorn oder ein glücklicher
nacktmull natürlich unglücklicher
nacktmull vielen dank für eure
glückwünsche und spaß wünsche für die
flitterwochen ihr wolltet außerdem
wissen wir es wahr wäre mir auf
instagram folgt weiß wir waren in der
sonne
dreieinhalb wochen in neuseeland und
dann noch drei tage in sydney ich bin
seit neuestem relativ aktiv bei
instagram ich habe das so ein bisschen
für mich entdeckt form einer youtube
zeit war ich nicht besonders aktiv auf
sämtlichen social media kann hier in
außer vielleicht auf facebook oder bei
instagram macht mir jetzt ziemlich viel
spaß und der grund warum ich so viel
werbung für instagram mache ist einfach
dass ich dir jetzt für mich entdeckt
habe das ist meine private count ich
werde nicht dafür bezahlt wie auch schon
spekuliert wurde uns auch einfach ganz
praktisch und auch ab und zu mal so paar
meiner nahrungsmenge zu machen was du an
steht auch außerhalb von youtube machen
hat mich jemand gefragt ob ich noch
science slams mache und ob man mich
irgendwo mal live sehen kann
ich mache jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt so
die klassischen science slams nicht mehr
so oft oder kauf noch aber ich gebe
viele vorträge die sind teilweise auch
sein slam artig so wissenschaftliches
thema aber möglichst unterhaltsam und
verständlich aufbereitet und diese
vorträge gebe ich immer mal wieder
eigentlich über in deutschland und das
kündige ich da noch an auf instagram in
den stories zum beispiel und wenn ihr
dann in der nähe seid in der stadt seid
könnt ihr natürlich vorbei kommen und
mir zuhören und wie hallo sagen oder mir
einmal ausgeben wie sieht dein
aufnahmeort aus hier hinten ist das
siegel auszeit ist studio
dann habe ich hier quasi die weise schön
schlauchen neuesten rathauses zwei
screens thiemann hoch und runter ziehen
kann freunde der sonne
news hier nehme ich die meisten videos
auf beziehungsweise auch teilweise
in meinem wohnzimmer oder meine küche
dass er auch schon gesehen habt ihr bei
schön schlauchen ob ich noch
irgendwelche instrumente spiele außer
ukulele ich habe früher natürlich geige
und klavier gespielt wie es sich gehört
für eine asiatin geiger klavier es
tatsächlich sehr stereotyp ich und ich
möchte unterstreichen dass meine eltern
mich nicht dazu gezwungen haben ich
wollte früher alle möglichen instrumente
spielen interessanterweise freundlich
eine zeitlang immer obwohl spielen ich
weiß wirklich nicht warum geige und
klavier ist es geworden mit geiger habe
ich angefangen unglaublich undankbares
instrument klavier habe ich geliebt ich
habe sehr viel gespielt werde ich in der
schule war ich habe sogar kurzzeitig
überlegt ob ich klavier studieren sollen
also ich 16 war assault meine
klavierlehrerin es mir gesagt dass wir
langsam zeit zu überlegen ob sie
pianistin werden will ist bei wenn jetzt
alle hieß eisenbahn um die schule zu
wechselte dann irgendwie ich weiß kann
ich nach hamburg oder sonst vorziehen
müssen und auf seine musik gymnasium
gehen müssen das aber das war mir zu
viel zeit generell so dass ich nicht
gerne nur eine sache mache bis zum
erbrechen was eine schlechte
voraussetzung wenn man pianist werden
möchte also wenn man pianist werden
möchte muss man glaubt den ganzen tag
üben und das wollen die übrige vielen
dank für euer vieles lob für meine
gesangseinlagen
ich nehme die dankend und demütig zur
kenntnis aber übertreibt man nicht hier
müsste mich mal unter der dusche hören
das klingt gut
[Musik]
aber mal im ernst ich würde sehr gerne
mal 11 musikvideo machen
ich bräuchte dazu eine unterstützung das
heißt martin fischer für laute wenn ihr
das seht schaust du breaking welt und
der big bang theory zu breaking welt bin
ich immer noch nicht gekommen
schlechte spiele mit dem big bang theory
ich da ab und zu mal reingeschaut also
ich habe nichts dagegen aber es gibt mir
irgendwie nix ich finde es einfach nicht
witzig viele haben mich gefragt wie ich
eigentlich auf chemie gekommen bin
wahrscheinlich im gegensatz zu vielen
anderen chemikern war chemie jetzt nicht
immer my one and only love gelesen also
ich fand schon immer geil keine frage
aber ich habe mich damals für sehr viele
verschiedene sachen interessiert das tue
ich immer noch und entsprechend wollte
ich auch sehr viele verschiedene sachen
studieren und es vielmehr relativ schwer
da eine entscheidung zu treffen
irgendwann habe ich mich zunächst mal
für allgemeinen naturwissenschaften
entschieden weil ich dachte
naturwissenschaften kann man nicht so
ohne weiteres so allein als hobby
verfolgt im gegensatz zu sprachen musik
oder politik deswegen dachte ich wenn
ich nicht naturwissenschaften studieren
dann werde ich bald gar nichts mehr mit
naturwissenschaften zu tun haben und das
konnte ich natürlich auf gar keinen fall
zulassen dann hab ich noch sehr sehr
lange überlegt ob ich chemie oder physik
studieren möchte darüber ob ich mir
wochenlang monatelang den kopf
zerbrochen am ende habe ich mich für
chemie entschieden ich finde es einfach
immer noch total abgefahren dass man
einfach dinge sachen wirkstoffe was was
ich wirkstoffe bis hin zu handy hüllen
aus polymeren quatsch aus molekülen
selbst machen kann selbst herstellen
kann aber physik hätte mir am ende
genauso viel spaß gemacht hat bin ich
mir ziemlich sicher und der ganzen
grenzen zwischen den naturwissenschaften
sind sowieso in einer ansichtssache
magst du verschwörungstheorien also
findest du es tust ich sie dir
anzuschauen ja auch aber ich finde sie
vor allem auch sehr faszinierend man
muss schon wertschätzen wie durchdacht
bis ins kleinste detail diese ganzen
verschwörungstheorien
und wie viel zeit und und gedanken aber
ist die leute die sich damit
beschäftigen investieren
fast schon wie ein wissenschaftler walt
falsch wusstet ihr zum beispiel dass die
flatrate hier sind die leute die denken
dass die erde eine scheibe ist das nicht
von einem planeten denken nein der mars
zum beispiel ist eine kugel den beim
mars kann man es offensichtlich dass er
ganz leicht nachweisen dass er eine
kugel ist im gegensatz zur erde ich habe
auch nie länger über die fällt öfter sei
die nachgedacht aber als ich das gehört
habe dachte ich mir was ist was denken
was glauben die eigentlich noch alles
gibt es noch weitere scheinen planeten
oder ist er die einzige scheibe vor
allem was ist unter der scheibe klebt
sich die scheibe irgendwie bewegt die
sich auch was passiert am rand der
scheibe kann man dahin reisen also kann
man dahin fliegen oder warum hat es noch
keiner gemacht drei ich habe so viele
frage glaubst du dass bäume die besten
tiere sind
nein also no fans bäume aber die besten
tiere sind natürlich locker ist
eigentlich gibt es fünf beste tiere
könnt ihr euch gerne mit schreiben das
ist ein fakt die fünf besten tiere in
keiner besonderen reihenfolge sind
pinguine krokos wombats ross die hamster
und zwei phasen
[Musik]
was ist der sinn des lebens fragt ist
mit elson
diese frage muss ich nicht beantworten
wie habt ihr schon beantwortet 42 jesus
kekse ist der sinn des lebens nicht
jener den du persönlich deinem 43 denn
jetzt noch jemand 42 antwortet dann
haben wir ihn gleich drei und die
antwort ist statistisch signifikant 42
hier gute alte manuel grilltag frank
unter anderem was quantenverschränkung
ist aber wozu soll ich mir die mühe
machen das zu erklären
darum kümmern sich ja schon julia und
nein mache ich nicht sehr viele wollten
wissen was ich gerade forscher oder
geforscht habe oder um was ist meine
doktorarbeit ihn in meiner forschung
habe ich mit drug delivery angefangen
dabei geht es ausnahmsweise nicht um
drogen und christmas und übrigens jahr
natürlich können die chemiker ein kann
oder kann jeder ausgebildete chemiker
drogen kochen es ist ein bisschen
kompliziert an gewisse ausgangsstoffe
dranzukommen
die schon dafür bekannt sind dass sie
für drogen verwendet werden aber zurück
zu drug delivery gibt ja zum beispiel
krebsmedikamente die durchaus wirksam
sind aber die gleichzeitig oder meistens
auch gleichzeitig schädlich sind
denn krebs medikamente sollen ihr
krebszellen zerstören
wie kriegt man das hin ohne gesunden
zellen zu schaden es gibt verschiedene
ansätze die chemiker verfolgen in der
krebstherapie manche chemiker versuchen
den wirkstoff selbst so zu verändern
dass er selektiver wird andere versuchen
den wirkstoff clever zu verpacken und
das sind in der regel polymer chemie
polymere sind lange molekülketten mit
denen polymer chemiker wie ich dann
transportvehikel oder verpackungen
herstellen könnt führt die wirkstoffe
und zwar auf dem nanometer maßstab also
es geht hier nicht um makroskopische
vielen oder tabletten sondern der
wirkstoff so hat eingespritzt werden und
dann durch die blutbahn zb zum krebs
geladen diese verpackung muss
verschiedene aufgaben erfüllen sie muss
dem wirkstoff vor dem immunsystem
schützen damit ja nicht einfach vom
körper entsorgt wird und was der
ankommen vorankommen will die verpackung
muss die krebszellen erkennen und
unterscheiden können
von gesunden zellen musste andocken
können irgendwie mussten wir uns oft in
die krebszellen einschleusten können und
dann natürlich in den zellen wieder
freisetzen das heißt die verpackung darf
jetzt nicht so stabil sein dass der
wirkstoff nie wieder freigesetzt wird
mir ja schwierig mega spannend sehr
cooles forschungsgebiet so fing meine
forschung an die habe ich dann auch in
die doktorarbeit mitgenommen und
eigentlich war ich gerade dabei ein
neues polymer für joggte livery zu
entwickeln als ich plötzlich zufällig
feststellte dass dieses polymer
eingebildet gehle kennt ihr auch aus dem
alltag hagel oder wackelpudding ist auch
in gel ein irgendwie festes aber doch
weiches und auch elastisches material
das zum großen teil aus wasser besteht
wie ein schwamm hydrogen anders diese
heterogene sind deswegen so interessant
für biomedizinische anwendungen weil sie
in ihren mechanischen eigenschaften ganz
ähnlich sein können zu biologischem
gewebe deswegen während hydrogel auch
als basis verwendet als gerüst um da auf
zellen zu züchten und so künstliche
gewebe herzustellen tissue engineering
mettmann dieses anwendungsgebiet ist auf
den ersten blick ein ganz anderes gebiet
als doktor livery chemisch gesehen aber
sehr ähnlich also das polymer muss
verträglich sein es muss wasserlöslich
sein es muss funktional sein also auf
seine umgebung reagieren können und so
kam ich dann diesen tissue engineering
bereich und habe ich jetzt in meiner
doktorarbeit über die letzten jahre
meiner doktorarbeit damit beschäftigt
dieses polymer dieses neue polymer zu
entwickeln mit dem man dann ein gel
herstellen kann das hoffentlich
irgendwann als basis für künstliches
gewebe eingesetzt werden könnte
jetzt bin ich letztes jahr fertig mit
der doktorarbeit und seit ich das
spielen fragen sich viele was ich jetzt
eigentlich genau mache außer youtube
nach der doktorarbeit habe ich mir erst
mal ein sabbatjahr von der forschung
genommen also ein jahr auszeit um das
mit funk zu probieren weil funk
zufälligerweise genau mit dem ende
meiner doktorarbeit zusammenfiel
diejenigen die mich schon länger schauen
und auch das sieht ein offside ist
kennen
wissen dass das damals sehr überraschend
kam weil ich glaube ich so 2000
abonnenten hat und gar nicht wusste die
funk überhaupt auf mich kam schien aber
nach einer seltsamen und einmaligen
gelegenheit ist gedacht ich mach das
jetzt einfach mal ein jahr und hatte vor
mir danach so wie die meisten chemiker
einen job in der industrie zu suchen
jetzt arbeite ich als dozentin für
slawik das ist kurz für das nationale
institut für wissenschafts kommunikation
nicht vermisse die forschung auf jeden
fall was mir aber in der vorschau auch
immer gefehlt hat ein bisschen war die
abwechslung die ich mir als sonst immer
in meinen hobbys gesucht habe denn weil
wir schon ein extremer fachidiot
inhalten sehr neugieriger mensch ich
möchte wissen wie dinge funktionieren
ich möchte dinge verstehen was
einerseits schon sehr gut zur forschung
braucht andererseits möchte ich auch ein
breiteres wissen haben und interessiere
mich eben für verschiedene sachen so
dass mir meine arbeit im moment
unglaublich viel spaß macht es gibt ein
video interview von mir wo ich erkläre
warum ich in die
wissenschaftskommunikation gegangen bild
wieder fragen mich warum ich da nicht
einfach in der forschung geblieben bin
verlinkt ich euch könnt ihr euch
anschauen falls ich euch interessiert da
macht natürlich youtube und wir
vielleicht auch wisst da auch
verschiedene sachen
und es gibt auch ein paar andere
projekte an denen ich arbeite zu denen
ich euch bei gelegenheit auch noch
abdecken werde 2010 geht ein spannendes
jahr werde ich euch noch alles erzählen
beim nächsten juni geht das licht aus
wenn die kühlschranktür zu mir das ist
ziemlich einfach herauszufinden
ja ich meine alles andere eine krasse
energieverschwendung viele wollen jetzt
natürlich wissen alle sich der
flitterwochen die ich matthias
kennengelernt habe sie sind jetzt seit
neun jahren zusammen und der aufmerksame
zuschauer kind macht hier ist natürlich
warum sehen weil er immer mal wieder in
meinen videos kurz zu sehen ist erst
nicht unglaublich gerne vor der kamera
aber wenn er gebraucht wird ist
natürlich da wir uns damals im studium
an der uni mainz kennen gelernt relativ
am ende des studiums er war ein semester
über meer aber irgendwie kannten uns
nicht oder hat uns nicht kennen gelernt
bis ganz zuletzt und ich hatte
mitbekommen dass er für ein
forschungsaufenthalt an sam geht also
für alle nicht netz das msi ist das
paradies ist quasi ein harvard nur für
naturwissenschaften und deswegen
natürlich viel cooler es hapert
natürlich wollte ich auch als energie
und wollte herausfinden wie er das
geschafft hat und ob ich das vielleicht
auch schaffe ich war auch schon immer so
ein bisschen satio sexuell veranlagt und
dachte werden dieser typ 1 mrd
hallo es stellte sich heraus der typ ist
nicht nur schnell sondern auch meine
seelenverwandte ich weiß das ist jetzt
ein bisschen eklig aber es ist wahr
es war insofern vielleicht nicht ganz
optimal weil wir am anfang sehr viel
fernbeziehung hatten wir lernten uns
kennen kurz bevor matthias für sieben
acht monate nach boston ging und bis wir
zusammen kam hatte ich mir schon einen
forschungsaufenthalt im folgejahr
organisiert das heißt in den ersten zwei
jahren unsere beziehung war erst sieben
acht monate in boston und danach bis
acht monaten post aber boss ist so ein
genialer ort zum forschen dass wir beide
immer wieder dahin zurück gegangen sind
und uns im zuge dessen immer besser
synchronisieren konnten also immer
größere überlappungen hatten demselben
land und irgendwann da nur noch
gemeinsam umgezogen sind
jetzt sind wir wieder in deutschland und
feind gottes wird also langes video ich
hoffe euch interessiert das überhaupt
alles deswegen zuletzt beantwortest du
diese frage
vielen dank fürs zuschauen bis hierhin
ich fühle mich total geschmeichelt dass
sie immer noch zu schaut jetzt wir sehen
uns nächsten donnerstag bis dahin bleibt
sicher
[Musik]